[Music]
so we are talking about about bill five
Michael you were reviewing it you've
been playing a lot of it I've been
playing a decent amount I don't know
like the more I play it the more I I
think I actually do like it you you were
kind of saying that today I'm just
coming in yeah I I went into it playing
or I'm gonna knock out the war stories
and I'm gonna of course I'm gonna play a
ton of conquest because battlefield has
always been built on conquest mode and
after you're doing the house I don't
know I'm not I wasn't feeling it at that
point the way maps are set up they don't
play well with conquest and I think
that's my main takeaway from playing so
much of that mode but then when I play
grand operations this is where this is
where battlefield starts to shine I
think and this is where everyone's
should be spending their time in this
game because there's a lot to it and
it's a it's a good way of highlighting
what makes battlefield a great series
because it's more focused it emphasizes
teamwork in a way that's not so overt
you just didn't buy that nature of the
way the modes are set up the objectives
and the Maps enforces you to be
cooperative and have those great
battlefield moments where things are
blown up but you're also getting kills
but you're dying also you're responding
and you're trying to it's this big tug
of war I think that's my favorite part
of battlefield sheriff I
George's place this game has two very
different identities it has the older
battlefield identity the larger larger
maps and cool systems that attrition and
fortifications work really well unlike
aerodrome fortifications work really
when all tanks work really well twisted
steel like another example of really
large map and then the other half of
this game which i think is like the
other four maps are designed for
close-quarters infantry fans who like
came in more around battlefield 3
playing a lot of metro and when the
player density gets that big for the
older players the game kind of stops
working in the way that you would want
it to work so like you start spawning in
and dying immediately getting shot in
the back or you build a fortification
that just gets rocketed a half a second
later yes you're in the building yeah
what's that what's even the point of
fortifying in conquest
you also get into the cycles though
where you you die and then you get
revived and they die they revive then
you get spit out somewhere else and then
that facing the wrong direction and like
it's disoriented like devastation is a
good example of I mean I know that you
you really like some of the interior
fights in the church particularly
because you know where the the enemy
team is don't put that on me boy I don't
know there are some times with that
devastation is with the church in the
middle right there that's the one where
I was playing like a few hours and I was
like I don't know what's going on here
I said that I get the the way it's set
up for certain modes but I do not like
that particular objective you do have a
point like with some of the maps being
definitely catered to like close
quarters
that's one map we're like I'll do
advanced search and I'll just remove it
if I'm playing a quest later there are a
couple where I just refuse to play or
I'll bounce out yeah um now that you
mentioned the identity thing I think
what you I get what you're saying now in
that this this goes into the way maps
are designed they're just like Narvik
conquest is to condense like they tried
to do a lot in such a small space for 64
players and I'm getting like cross fired
from objectives all the way across the
map and I'm like what the hell like it
negates the what you're supposed to be
doing in battlefield feeling of
accomplishment in a map that you're like
taking something and it means something
that's when the game's not working on
those small maps and again maybe people
who like small inventory focused stuff
will like those when the game is working
on the larger maps like twisted steel I
will say that there's a lot of enjoyment
around old-school battlefield vehicle
combat there's fast tanks and slow tanks
I mean your your big pilot the airplanes
are I I'm conflicted like the vehicle
game and definitely the airplane game or
combat game has dropped for the series
after three like the moment in four were
like you start off and you just are
thrown right into a plane in midair it
was like one of the biggest letdowns for
me I've ever had cuz I yeah I mean since
1942 I've been like obsessed with flying
and here it's just another another
pick or like they just seem to forget
what it is you're supposed to be doing
in a point yeah it definitely feels at
the emphasize yeah like air combat and
tanks somewhat to a degree but
especially airplanes they feel like an
afterthought at this point what's the
biggest bummer for me and this is why
where I was pretty pissed off about it
and you know like three also had that
implementation where it was like okay
you know you you need some kind of
progression for vehicles that's fair and
three they you know rockets right
probably the best thing about flying was
like you could they're multi-purpose so
you can use it in the air you can use
them on the ground like they're dope
they're like that's like the last thing
you unlock that's fair like I'm still
able to have an impact on the ground
here and this is what's so infuriating
is like if you go here I got pulled up
baby this full oh my god I'm all about
it but it's just this is so frustrating
is if you look at progression here oh
and by the way like I have to progress
into two ways right one there's access
and allied no dude this will brought the
receipts dude look at this though if I'm
in a fighter right I have to wait until
I'm ranked three which isn't actually
that's not too bad ranked three four
bombs right so currently right now I'm
flying with just just guns yes yeah I
can't do [ __ ] if there are no other
enemy planes flying around it is
pointless
but there's I'm supposed to be getting
experience I'm supposed to be working
toward something but I can't get
experience if all I'm doing is just
waiting for an enemy plane hopefully I
can shoot them down you sure sell it
like can't do anything on it like an
enemy
so I think the good news is that the
rock-paper-scissor approach it's in the
game but it's not activated it's not
working right so it's supposed to be
rock-paper-scissors supposed to be tank
beats infantry airplane beats tank and
now it should be tank towing flat gun
beats airplane right so all these
systems are in the game but you start
with airplanes that can't see ground
troops because there isn't currently
very good spotting system they don't
have the weapons to do it so you you you
don't have the tank the
rock-paper-scissors like that's broken
when you start and then towing is kind
of a mess because things that you
tourist scattered around the map and not
really like well-thought-out so yeah
it's like very simple small things they
can and this game is gonna be going for
a while but if you just turn the turret
around right like the way the system is
right now you have to walk into a tank
then you have to go back up to a turret
then you have to tow it to where you
think it's gonna be useful then you have
to unhinge it but turn it around then oh
yeah
turn it around then do another u-turn
and hope it like somebody gets what
you're after yeah that's a good point
like you have to be in the same mindset
of like that's it requires new station
there's too many steps to make that an
effective thing especially in
battlefield where like shits popping off
every second with how dense these maps
are to even like twisted steel which is
one of the bigger maps you're gonna get
gunned down or you're gonna get attacked
at any second there's no time for that
really at least I haven't seen an
instance where that would make sense for
me yeah I just feel like the vehicles in
this series have been continually an
afterthought and you know that's not how
most people play I guess but for me it's
like one of the biggest parts about
coming to this game because it's the one
thing that really sets it apart from
like Call of Duty right it's like
vehicle it's like a battlefield the
short of it is it's like there seems to
be like such a thinning of the
progression where you really have to
spend a lot of time and that's what
that's what that's what number is
dialing in my head it's like yeah this
is gonna be like maybe 10 hours 20 hours
to get the bombs and then I can start
actually helping my team otherwise there
is no Drive and also the fact that you
have to like look into those vehicles
when you spawn it's there's so there's
so the moments to actually use them
effectively are so few and far between
so like having tying vehicle progressed
in so many different directions feels a
little like that's one area of the
progression that I do not like at all I
missed that I miss the days of being
able to spawn and like run into a planet
yeah oh yeah now I'm in a menu hitting
my goddamn mouth
clicker is like fast as I can so someone
just get it for me they don't give a
[ __ ] about the ending of progression is
kind of an interesting point because
battlefield 5 is seems to be playing the
long game
so the a lot of the content that they
talked about originally is not gonna be
here until we'll be rolling out between
now and March so a lot of the the next
deal say the last Tiger is gonna be a
lot of the tank combat so it's kind of
we're in a weird launch window where a
lot of this stuff might be there within
the next three months yeah that's
another thing too that they're asking
you to pay full price for one game in my
mind it goes both ways because it's like
yeah I'll pay one price and I'm gonna
get all this other content but at the
same time the launch package is it might
feel like there's something missing
there because they have say a December
we're gonna roll up this new stuff I'm
gonna roll up these in this new mode or
new maps and then in March we're gonna
have battle royale so it's kinda like oh
snap like if I buy this game like
there's so much to look forward to right
some people might feel like might be
optimistic about that approach some
people might be like oh I'm getting
there cheeping out on the launch package
yeah so I'm in caught it I'm kind of
thinking between that because like I'm
having fun with the launch package
because of how much I like the ground
game how much I like frontlines and
break through and how its packaged into
grand operations like I can play that
mode for four days and I'm getting a lot
out of it so if I'm gonna shell out like
60 bucks for this game and like grand
operations and the modes packed within
that or what I'm focusing on and I'm
just like pounding away on the ground
game then
I'm satisfied with what's there now some
people say like oh well battlefields
have been doing this for a long time
already like well then what's new for it
and you know if that's your concern
that's fair for me I just want like a
really good packaged World War 2 game in
the modern sense and that's kind of what
I'm getting out of this so in that
regard I'm enjoying it especially with
those modes that are in grant operations
where everything feels focused
it feels chaotic but it's manageable
yeah and that's you know I'm getting a
lot out of that
does the game feel like it's there for
you right now and or like how much
further down the road does it need to
get for it to feel like it really
depends on what you want and what I want
out of the game is there now you know I
can't speak for everyone obviously
because there's so much stuff in
battlefield like throughout the series
that there are a lot of players who seek
out different things in the series and
for me it's all about you know large
scale infantry combat and that's there
with the modes within grant operations
and conquest
I don't know I'm burned out upon
conquest and even more so after playing
all these maps on complex like I don't
want to touch that mode no more so I'm
thankful that you know things like
frontlines and breakthrough and airborne
and all packaging the ground breaches is
there like that's I'm satisfied with
having just that yeah it's interesting
like hearing you talk about of the other
modes that aren't conquest like that
seems to be just the most promising part
like conquest just it's like it's a it's
it's evolved or devolved like over the
years right like it's currently it feels
like such a mess yes yeah yeah I think
the it boils down to the design
philosophy I think it's where like maybe
you they don't want players to feel like
there's a there's too many quiet moments
in between because when I think back to
1942 there's a lot of their non-combat
for sure
yeah and there and so I think that now
in the modern sense is like hey we need
action happening all the time and when
that's the thing that you want to go for
it yeah like just devolved into a
carousel of flat captures and kills and
that's not fun
no you know you're totally right and I
miss those days of like I would rather
have that I'd rather have like certain
maps in battlefield I think over it's
like you die and you have to go to like
a outpost and all the vehicles are gone
you're like I guess I better walk Oh 10
minutes was walking from A to B I kind
of Miss that like it's I've had one or
two of those moments already actually a
game yeah there's one or two maps where
that happens I'm really curious where
this game is gonna be yeah in a couple
months YouTube you know as you said like
it's a good kicking off point and it's
gonna have content added over time I
will probably play a bit now and then
wait for the new content so I start
rolling out and jump into the big tank
battle when it happens and wait for
firestorm and those other modes see how
they handle rush but if you it feels
like every other battle game it's like
real messy at launch and they kind of
get it all together they call it all
together eventually yeah yeah that's
good playing so in that sense it's it's
not unusual for a battlefield launch to
be met okay yeah that's fair yeah that's
probably the biggest takeaway is like
just it's time to be patient with that
game and see where it is December March
yeah two years from now
[Music]